and here they are the new air plants Pro
[Music]
[Applause]
today we are checking out the new air
quads Pro these were just announced by
Apple that I'm so excited to check them
out these are the newest line of Pro
products to join the Apple lineup
you may be wondering what's the
difference between these and the regular
air pods let's unbox and find out and
here they are the first thing that
you're gonna notice is the case is
slightly larger but it's weird because
it's kind of just like squished the
other way new air pods old air pods at
checkout you also have the option of
engraving your ear pods much like I did
in my previous gen which I'm so happy I
did because I get these confused for
people's all the time but guess what not
anymore because my name is on it so the
case kind of just looks like it got
squished a little bit because the size
isn't really that much different it's
just a little bit larger alright let's
open them up so the main highlight of
the brand-new air pause pro is the fact
that they have noise cancellation and it
has active noise cancellation but it
also has a transparency mode and with
this transparency mode you're able to
hear the outside world so to make all of
that possible they had to redesign what
the actual air pod looks like these now
have a little in-ear silicone tip on
them and also inside the box are two
other size options in case the one that
comes with it doesn't fit there's a
little microphone and each one of these
inside of your ear so the air pod is
actually able to hear what you're
hearing and with that they're able to
make adjustments to outside sound to
really make the active noise
cancellation work this also comes with
something else that I'm excited about
which I feel like this is moving us
closer and closer to us b/c this comes
with a USBC to a lightning cable
let's get these paired to my phone
immediately one of things that's so
great about air pods is you basically
just have to get it close to your
and will automatically start pairing and
they're connecting connecting media
control so this is showing you how to
use them so what's different with these
ones is they have this little button
right here so there's different presses
that you can press to activate different
things like changing tracks switching
from transparency mode to noise
canceling also pretty cool because you
can do all of these things inside of the
control center before you do anything
you should do they're a little fit test
that they have so you go into your
Bluetooth settings and this is one of
the places that you control the
transparency or you can turn both off
just to have nothing normal earpods
and you can also activate the noise
cancellation this can also be activated
by swiping down and doing a long press
on the volume noise cancellation of
transparency this option is also
available on the Apple watch and if
that's not enough if you do a long press
that will also switch between the
different options as well so right now
I'm in transparency and it's so weird
I've used so many headsets that have
this kind of setting that lets the
outside noises in what's so wild about
this I don't even know how to explain it
because if you ever use these types of
things before it seems to make your
voice
super super loud so you just sound extra
loud inside of your head and then the
whole world around you also sounds
really loud but it's kind of like this
heightened sense and it's very strange
but with this I honestly feel like I
forget that I even have them on so
before I get into testing these out I
need to do my fit test so I have to make
sure that these fit well in my ear and I
feel like this I think it might be a
little bit too big so I'm going to
switch these to the smaller option and
these are really so easy to just take
off of here you just I need to do the
same thing on here and it's weird
because I feel like I'm gonna break it
but it has a really snug little seal and
you just pop it right off and you pop
the new one right on and you
so keep this to house those previous
ones okay so now that these feel like
they're fitting pretty snug let's go
back into Justine's air Potts Pro and
this here is the ear tip fit test so
using those internal microphones it's
able to hear what you're hearing to make
sure that there's actually a good seal
between your ear and the inner ear
silicon tip so let's test the fit of
your ear tips there we go it's playing a
little song for me and here it is these
are my ear tip fit results it says I
have a pretty good seal okay so I feel
like this is one of those things that
you were just gonna have to test out and
see what works best for you so crazy
because I'm using the transparency mode
so doesn't even feel like I have these
in my ears at all now I want to play
some music these also have Siri
integration so if I want to listen to
something I just have to say play the
new tool album okay so I'm still using
the transparency mode and if I want to
switch to noise cancellation I'm just
gonna hold this in okay now it's oh gosh
this is so crazy it's wrong I just you
guys are sitting there just watching me
like do weird things and make weird
expressions so without you actually
being able to try this so what I'm doing
is I'm pressing on here one press to
skip tracks play or answer a call two
presses to skip tracks three presses to
go back a track and the long press that
switches between the noise cancellation
and the transparency mode so there's so
many different options and ways for you
to switch into these different modes so
it's kind of crazy that that's just
another way to do it you could also do
this you can even ask Siri to turn it on
and off for you turn on noise
cancellation turn off the noise
cancellation and just like that Syrians
turned it off so far I really like you
can be used a lot when I first saw the
rumors of these types I had four omens
from Apple I got a little bit nervous
because a lot of times these don't work
with my ears I'm very
sensitive ears so I am beyond excited to
reports that my sensitive ears are not
bothered by these at all and it's kind
of crazy because a lot of times noise
cancelling headphones like this release
some sort of weird pressure but this
also has a little thing it's got like
this little airflow event that they've
included so that allows for air flow to
kind of go inside of your ear so it
makes a much more natural feel so let me
give you a side-by-side comparison over
the old and the new air pods because
it's crazy the size difference I mean
look at this new air pod old air pod old
air pod new air BOTS so you're looking
kind of like straight on you can already
instantly tell the difference the little
antenna is way shorter on the new one
[Music]
so I had to go somewhere kind of outside
of my office to really test these out
the Sun is about to set so I thought I
wouldn't go to my favorite coffee shops
get myself a latte so I can stay up all
night editing this video for you guys
and it's crazy because right now I'm
using the transparency on the new air
pods and there's traffic
there's people but I can hear all of it
until I tell Siri to turn on noise
cancellation turn on noise cancellation
I hear a slight rush of traffic
Nili play the new tool album
let's go into the setting you can see
the like noise cancellation is on
now that I have the volume turned up a
little more I actually can't hear
anything else turn off the noise
cancellation
the transparency is odd I can hear the
traffic I can hear my music and now that
is where the noise cancellation back on
this is so great I'm so excited for you
guys to actually experience this if you
do get these I can still hear a slight
bit of traffic with the mix of the music
and the noise cancellation it sounds
amazing I don't even really know how to
do this demo for you guys because you
can't experience what I'm hearing so I
can only sort of explain it let's put a
noise cancellation back on surprise I
don't hear anything we seem to be losing
light now so the Sun is setting so I'm
actually go back home and I'm an edit
this entire video using the new air pods
so back to my unboxing room this case is
also a wireless charging case much like
the new case that just came out in the
last version the air pods
I did get a chance to try these on a
flight and I was really impressed mostly
because you kind of just always
consistently hear this just airplane
sound it's just like a Shh
it's just so even when I wasn't even
listening to music just turning on the
active noise cancellation just put me at
peace and then while playing music and
with the active noise cancellation on it
really did drown out pretty much
everything so with the air pods Pro
you'll get five hours of listening time
but if you have active noise
cancellation or transparency on you'll
get about four and a half and about
three and a half hours of talk time but
with a five minute charge that will give
you an extra hour of listening time in
this entire case will provide you with
about 24 hours of listening time so if
that's not enough time to get you
through your day I'm not sure what is
something else that I'm excited to try
out is the IO sharing so if I'm
listening to some music or watching a
movie and my friend wants to also listen
or watch my movie over my shoulder on a
flight make a new audio sharing so all
your friend has to do is bring their ear
paws close to yours I can temporarily
share my audio since these are my ear
pods I guess I'm temporarily sharing
them with myself but that's pretty great
so what I clicked it to connect it's
just giving me this option to
temporarily connect you can now listen
to music watch a video or play games
together
holy-moly done okay so Mike like these
are in someone else's ear right now
play a Macklemore and Ryan Lewis thrift
shop just seen theropods who are
connected and hearing ously you have the
volume options for both air pod sets
this is so great it obviously since I
have the pro version I can click in and
I can change my noise cancellation text
Jenna is Eric and ask her if she likes
candy so I have this set up so that
it'll read
text messages and then you can
automatically respond from there as well
using hey Siri so she just read the
message to me that said OMG yeah sad
crying face
me too I'm making a video and thinking
about Halloween candy it has a little
notification that it says that it was
sent with Siri I really like that
because a lot of times I mean it's no
secret that sometimes Siri thinks that
you're saying something and you're not
saying the correct thing so this will at
least give context I know there's
definitely some times that I have
written some very lengthy things to
Jenna and it's very obvious that it is a
voice to text so this is really great
because this will actually let them know
that you're not typing it and you're
hands-free so if you do get the new ear
pods make sure you're updated to the
latest iOS on your phone so that you'll
be able to use all of the features I
really love the audio sharing I think
that's probably one of my favorite
things so far especially for traveling
and different flights and playing games
together my first impressions I'm
actually way more impressed than I
thought I was gonna be I love the case I
love the design I love the fit I am in
love with the transparency mode I would
love to know what you guys think of
these what is your first impressions
having not even seen them yet I'll be
making a follow-up video probably within
a week or so after I've really got a
chance to try these out test them in the
wild edit with them and listen to music
and probably play a lot of Call of Duty
mobile if anybody else been playing Call
of Duty mobile because it is so
incredibly fun I'd hope the new call of
duty modern warfare just came out I've
been playing that a lot on Xbox as well
but the mobile version is so much better
than I thought it was gonna be and I'm
really good at it I don't know if I'm
just good or everybody else is terrible
maybe a combination of both but that's a
whole nother story
anyway airpot don't forget to subscribe
so you'll be able to see all of my
future videos and be sure to hit the
bell you'll be notified when I do post
new videos I've got a bunch of great
content coming up for you there is we're
just continuing this month of incredible
tech gadgets so I'll see you guys in my
next video bye
[Music]